[Musique]
l'ucm israël est bienvenue pour le
qu'affiche politique je vous en prie
installez-vous nous allons à débuter
cette émission par une petite
présentation vous êtes élue au conseil
municipal de trappes dans l'opposition
conseiller communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines et avant tout alors
vous allez me corriger ou pas constitue
qu'on vous situe bien à gauche
vous êtes toujours adhérent au parti
communiste français font de gauche
comment vous présente aujourd'hui alors
déjà je suis élu conseiller municipal à
trappes dans l'opposition mais
l'opposition de gauche et d un puisqu'il
ya deux autres précisions bien même
trois maintenant
et oui je suis membre du parti
communiste du front de gauche qui est un
rassemblement composé essentiellement de
citoyens qui veulent pas forcément ce
encarté dans un parti politique quel
qu'il soit mais qu'il souhaite avoir une
action citoyenne et donc qu'ils se
retrouvent dans le front de gauche le
par les valeurs qu'il véhicule
et cet engagement à gauche remonte à
quand ça fait très longtemps que vous
êtes sur le terrain frappe ça fait très
longtemps qu'on vous voit vous présenter
à différentes différents différents
postes que ce soit pour le ce soit pour
le département pour la région pour le
sénat aussi on vous a vue sur
différentes listes
il remonte à caen cet engagement alors
bye remonte à très longtemps on peut
dire que peut-être il fait partie un peu
d'une éducation que j'ai reçu puisque
mon père était lui-même communiste mais
ma mère pas engager plus que ça mais
avec des valeurs de gauche
ma soeur elle sait pas du tout donc
voilà c'est comme ça mais bon il ya une
éducation derrière tout ça je vais
adhérer très jeune au parti communiste
18 19 ans et puis j'ai toujours eu une
implication pas uniquement politique
beaucoup aussi dans le monde associatif
notamment sportifs mais également dans
l'humanitaire et aujourd'hui j'imagine
que vous êtes déçu de voir la gauche
aussi divisés lorsqu'on est engagé a
depuis aussi longtemps et de voir
qu'aujourd'hui mais à gauche les choses
sont compliquées
la déception elles portent plus sur la
déception des gens par rapport à l'image
qu'ils ont dago ch et là on à l'héritage
d'une gauche qui a été complètement
phagocyter
notamment par l'ère mitterrand qui a la
foi a regroupé
pour faire barrage à la droite et
accéder au pouvoir
une partie de personnes qui ont rien à
voir avec les valeurs de gauche
d'ailleurs on voit bien aujourd'hui la
république en marche
c'est un melting-pot assez
indescriptible et derrière tout ça
les valeurs de gauche se trouve
complètement atteinte alors que je pense
que tous sont des valeurs d'avenir que
c'est celle que je défends et qui
incarne le mieux la gauche aujourd'hui
jean-luc mélenchon s'est dit qu'on
présente le plus en tant que chef de
cette opposition
non il n'y a pas de chef ce qui
représente le mieux la gauche c'est les
valeurs et les valeurs cd visor
quelqu'un pour les carnets le prix
souvent oui mais ça c'est un des
problèmes de la politique française par
exemple nous on pense plus qu'il faut
travailler collectif et qu'il faut
travailler en équipe et
c'est d'ailleurs une des petites
différences parmi d'autres que l'on a
avec jean luc mélenchon mais
donc c'est un acteur indéniable de
l'opposition réellement à gauche mais il
y en ad'autres jean luc mélenchon fait
tout pour accrocher les médias ils y
arrivent très bien parfois de manière un
peu caricaturale ça c'est son problème
mais il ya des questions qu'il faudrait
se poser quand même pourquoi on voit
aussi peu le front de gauche les
communistes dans les médias alors que
c'est eux qui ont le plus de
parlementaires par rapport à la france
est soumise par exemple alors que au
niveau des élus locaux
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a réussi
à garder un groupe au sénat au sein des
élus locaux alors de très loin derrière
les autres mais c'est le troisième
groupe politique j c'est à dire qu'il ya
les républicains il ya parti socialiste
enfin recomposé et puis derrière donc il
ya une présence de terrain moi vous
demandiez ce qui me caractérise ce qui
me caractérise c'est la présence de
terrain je vais vous citer de noms qui
vont pas forcément vous plaire ariane
chemin raphaëlle bacqué grand reporter
au monde qui viennent de publier un
ouvrage qui s'appelle la communauté et
qui parle justement de cette ville de
trappes on dresse le portrait de cette
ville dans cet ouvrage on cite forcément
les noms au d'omar sid nicolas anelka ou
encore jamel debbouze
on parle aussi d'une commune détentrice
d'un triste record européen celui du
nombre de jeunes candidats au jihad qui
sont partis en syrie 67 personnes vous
l'avez lu que j'imagine cet ouvrage et
vous a pas beaucoup plus c'est à dire
que je ne comprends pas bien déjà son
utilité fait l'effet en grand reporter
je sais pas mais moi j'en lèvres est
grand parce que déjà c'est je parle pas
des choix éditoriaux qui leur
appartienne ça j'ai rien à dire là
dessus si ce n'est que je suis pas tout
à fait d'accord avec certaines de leurs
approches on peut en discuter mais par
contre il est quand même cousu de
nombreuses inexactitudes et erreur donc
pour un travail comme vous dites de
grand reporter soit il a été bâclée ou
alors il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas
sur le sur le fond déjà le titre est
ambigu parce que la communauté donc à la
communauté on peut entendre la ville
comme ils sous-entendent c'est que c'est
une ville à part et c'est pour une part
c'est juste
mais pour une large part aux six et
c'est faux il y à tout un tas de choses
de manières d'investigation
journalistique auraient pu être faites
et qui ne sont pas là dedans parce que
faire l'état de constat c'est une chose
après si on écrit un livre de 300 pages
que j'ai lu avec beaucoup d'attention
c'est pour apporter quelque chose de
plus et bien là on voit pas suffisamment
à mon avis le travail d'analysé et pas
suffisamment de perspectives parce que
ça induit pour ceux qui vont lire trop
vite et ceux qui vont pas lire du tout
ils font tout de suite la transition sur
c'est une ville communautariste mais
c'est faux après ya une réalité un agent
mais le réalisme 67 jeunes qui partent
faire de toi là-bas et série voilà tout
à fait je moi je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya
pas du communautarisme dans la ville ce
que je dis pas ce qu'est ce qui peut par
une lecture rapide traversée c'est que
c'est une ville communautariste les
chiffres des élections dernière montre
que c'est pas vrai c'est à dire que sûr
il y a
beaucoup de musulmans sur la sur la
ville
mais sur les élections et c'est la
différence qu'on fait avec ses lustres
communautariste c'est que nous on pense
que d'abord c'est les valeurs humaines
les valeurs sociales qu'il faut défendre
et la qualité de vie des gens et les
difficultés qu'ils rencontrent et donc à
partir de là ce qu'on va mettre en place
cdd politique au service de tous
je vous cite un exemple oui c'est du
communautarisme
moi quand je vais au marché quand je
vais chez un marchand et c'est ce que
moi j'habite trappe
donc j'y vais régulièrement mais ça
manque pas que j'entende merci mon frère
merci ma soeur et moi quand je passe
derrière chez certains je l'entends pas
alors je les interpelle
jardim mais moi je suis pas votre frère
humain alors il y en a certains qui
répondent pas donc on a compris et qu'il
y en a certains qui répondront oui
pardon c'est vrai c'est juste voilà donc
cette ville est trop caricaturé et donc
rien que le titre
il permet pas de travailler là dessus et
nous ce qu'on essaye de faire c'est
travailler là dessus de manière plus
fondamentale avec la population en
essayant de de renforcer les solidarités
avec les moyens qu'on a qui sont
forcément limitée et vous parler d'
inexact d'inexactitudes pardon dans cet
ouvrage pourrait en citer un nom de à
trouver quelles sont les choses qui vous
ont interpellé alors bon enfin il ya
déjà des tas de choses fausses ou bon
mais mais c'est pas l'aspect majeur du
livre un jeu vous l'accord d'un soir
l'aspect majeur du livre c'est que déjà
le communisme municipal et gentiment
caricaturer on attend les avaient été
leurrés sollicité par les journalistes
qui ont travaillé sur leur âge par
exemple n'ont alors ça c'est un autre
point
on m'a dit mettez cités dans le livre tu
les as rencontré un gênant je les ai
jamais rencontrés
d'accord
donc voilà peut-être que il aurait pu
tête de liste d'une liste de gauche et
carrick deuxième aux dernières
municipales puis ça aurait peut-être pu
les interpeller
mais peut-être qu'ils ont d'autres choix
éditoriaux puis peut-être qu'ils sont là
aussi pour promouvoir autre chose
c'est-à-dire le fait que oui mais ça
c'est de l'histoire c'était bien gentil
hein
c'est légèrement condescendant non les
valeurs de justice sociale et de progrès
social
elles sont toujours d'actualité et on
nous dit qu'on n'est pas moderne mais ce
qui est en place c'est à dire que le
pouvoir est aux puissants et aux
cuissons fortunés mais ça ça fait des
millénaires que ça dure donc ça c'est
pas moderne du tout et quand on parle
par exemple de civilisation de quelle
civilisation on veut il ya un il ya la
civilisation humaine
2 il ya différentes civilisations qu'il
faut apprendre à mieux connaître etc
mais nous on s'oppose à cette notion par
exemple de choc des civilisations non
nous on veut mieux vivre tous ensemble
et c'est possible on n'a jamais eu
autant de ressources financières pour le
faire après c'est des choix qui passe
par la répartition de ces richesses
énormément de de combat on l'a entendu
toujours la même détermination vous
allez mener un nouveau combat politique
cette fois ci sur le terrain pour un
nouveau mandat vous le savez déjà où il
ya un moment où vous allez vous dire je
passe la main
mais déjà la politique c'est pas que les
élections la politique c'est la vie de
la cité tous les jours donc on a tous
les jours quelque chose à faire pour
améliorer le vivre ensemble
donc ça je continue mais après incarner
une liste lors d'une annexion par
exemple abbas est tout à fait possible
et actuellement il ya des tas de gens
qui une sollicitation à la fois au
travers de ce livre ou alors oui mais
c'est plus possible ce qui se passe là
c'est plus possible et donc cette équipe
qui s'est constituée pour les élections
de 2014
et puis il y compris des personnes qui
la rejoignent parce que il y en a
certains qui étaient un petit peu
indécis etc
mais il ya des tas de gens qui en ont
assez d'une politique avec evian ça va
pas lui faire plaisir mais monsieur
hamon qui débarquent ici son fief
trappistes mais n'a jamais habité ici il
a été parachuté ici aujourd'hui on voit
très très peu un jour on va le revoir
parce que il va soutenir se disant
monsieur alliera b puisque le taux
proclamation a eu lieu
bon ben on verra mais moi je n'oublie
pas que monsieur hamon ministre a été
ministre de monsieur valls et 1 alors
s'il est étiqueté parti socialiste on
savait pas lire dans le marc de café
pour savoir la politique qu'il allait
faire et qu'ensuite il y avait voté ce
budget quand il était député qu'il était
plus ministre
donc c'est d'une autre politique que ça
qu'on a besoin parce que la catastrophe
elle est là dans livre on parle de son
site et ses ingérences père étrangères
mais mais qu'est-ce que peut une ville
par rapport à ça mais qu'est ce qu'a
fait qu'est ce qu'on fait les différents
ministres de l'intérieur
qu'est-ce qu'on fait les différents
gouvernements qu'est-ce qu'on fait les
services secrets ils travaillent ils
savent ils savent l'essentiel on nous
parle des djihadistes oui mais vous
savez moi quand on parle des jihadistes
je pense il y en a certains c'est ancré
dans la culture la famille etc
c'est une chose y en a d'autres et c'est
l'essentiel est les premiers surpris
c'est la famille et et moi je pense
toujours aux mamans parce que quand tu
en a un qui se fait tuer qu'on l'apprend
mais la maman elle a perdu aussi un fils
il ya des frères et soeurs qui ont perdu
un frère illias etc etc et donc tous
tout ça est difficile puis on a vu aussi
qui en a certains qui sont partis il y
en a qui était déjà revenu ça fait déjà
plusieurs mois plusieurs années si qui
ont eu le sentiment d'avoir été trompés
et d'ailleurs qui mène une bataille de
terrain pour expliquer ça ben voilà
comment on travaille avec tout ça pour
encore une fois enrichir le vivre
ensemble
en effet pour vivre ensemble on a les
moyens de le faire pourquoi on ne fait
pas toujours la même détermination
toujours merci l'utiliserai d'avoir
participé au café politique merci merci
bien
[Musique]
oui
et